this video is taken near the eye of a
category 4 hurricane in the middle of
the Atlantic with waves as high as a
four-story building and winds reaching
94 miles an hour the National Oceanic
and Atmospheric Administration is
sending three state-of-the-art drones a
each with its own important mission
straight into the center of these
monster storms
drones are a new piece of technology
that is helping us uncover information
about the storms that we didn't know
before let's take a look inside Noah's
lab to see how the agency uses drones to
dive sail and fly into parts of a
hurricane where humans could never go
oh
at the laboratory a team of NOAA
Engineers work on this torpedo-shaped
drone called the glider it's five feet
long can weigh up to 150 pounds and it's
controlled by drone Pilots like Yuli
Rivero a glider could cost anywhere from
175 000 to 200 000 depending on what
sensors are they're equipped with Those
sensors are used to track storms half a
mile beneath the ocean surface measuring
water temperatures along the way
is not a handle this is where you have
the conductivity depth and temperature
sensor in here and this is a dissolve
oxygen the unit can find the warmest
sections of water which can intensify
hurricanes normally we dive into 900
meters and it takes about four hours so
it's about six Dives per day the drones
collect data underwater and send it to
computers like this using satellite
radio waves so one of the things we want
to know is when the glider goes into the
water if you look here this is the
actual track of what the glider did and
you see this is like almost a perfect
v-shape which is what we strive for when
the drones Surface after each dive they
transmit their location to yuli's
computer which shows up as those little
dots between the lines
so here is a map of where our gliders
are right now so we have gliders south
of Puerto Rico we streak that is right
here one south of the Dominican Republic
and one north of Puerto Rico while
gliders take measurements underwater
sail drones track what's happening on
the ocean's surface they want to get the
cell drawn to be at the same location as
the glider this way you have information
from the surface down and then also you
know atmospheric information because the
cell does have the capability of doing
that built for extreme conditions the
robots are 23 feet long with a 15 foot
Wing that powers the Drone and solar
panels that power the sensors these
sensors test surface level temperature
wave height wind speed and salinity or
how fresh the water is and if they are
fresh we know that they will remain in
the surface
that water is also warm it indicates a
site that could
in hurricane
so one of Gustavo ghoni's teams marks
those areas on a map to keep an eye on
and when a hurricane is coming the
robots can sail Straight Into the Storm
under those conditions it has to conduct
observations and transmit them
2022 was the first year that Noah
deployed gliders and sail drones to the
same areas of the Atlantic and this
season Noah is adding super tough new
aerial drones that can fly through the
200 mile per hour winds around the eye
of a hurricane these drones provide us
that information from the temperature
the relative humidity the pressure
information wind wind speed and wind
direction all of those factors are key
on how we understand how the hurricane
is is evolving that data goes into the
computer models so that we can better
forecast what's going to happen the next
day and so on Charlie Morello is in
charge of the hurricane research
department at the lab
for years hurricane hunter planes have
flown above hurricanes to take
measurements oh there goes the songs
today aerial drones are launched from
those planes flying into the eye of the
storm giving experts a wealth of new
data about how these monster storms
intensify hurricane intensity is a tough
nut to crack there are so many different
pieces of the puzzle that need to be
solved from looking at the different
layers of the atmosphere from vertically
to horizontally to to different time
scales from the air scientists at these
stations pilot the drones gliding them
like Hawks into gale force winds
sometimes closer than 100 feet from the
ocean's surface
last year Noah flew this drone the
Altius 600 into the eye of a category 4
hurricane for over two hours
but the Drone crashed and wasn't
recovered
we experiment with aerial drones to see
which one is going to give us the best
information at the best time while we're
flying in the storm and so it you know
it's a trial and error for the 2023
season Noah is also using black Swift s0
and Dragoon drones with a new probe that
can measure vertical winds allowing
researchers to predict how long a storm
will last at its highest intensity as
NOAA scientists continue to chart the
seas in anticipation of hurricanes they
see the information provided by drones
as vital
these data sets whether it's in the
ocean under the water or even in the air
there are key piece for us to understand
and forecast those storms